i've always been really passionate about
the challenge of thinking forward on
what our things are made out of that we
use every day
i do like to create something that
speaks for itself so somebody can look
at it and see the craftsmanship that
goes into it and also make them think
about how it was created and why what
the motivation is
and that keeps me inspired to really
push the ball forward in terms of how a
surfboard is made
we're surfers we're in the ocean and we
have a reverence for the place that
we're in i think it's kind of paying
homage to that as well
[Music]
surfboard sales particularly in the last
few years have absolutely called through
the roof
and
that's both a good thing and a bad thing
it means that there's probably three
times as many surfers in the water now
which means three times as many
surfboards that are made from
unsustainable materials like fossil
fuels oils resins things that are
actually used to make most surfboards
and so
people
have been exploring original material
for building surfboards like wood in
really innovative and unique ways danny
hess here in san francisco is probably
the leading light on that
my goal is to make them
accessible for people
we're not trying to mass produce
surfboards here we're not trying to make
as many as we can as fast as we can
i'm just focused on creating boards that
the craftsmanship and quality is
foremost
one of the greatest motivations was that
i was taking salvaged wood and really
just trying to push the ball forward and
just see what alternative materials that
aren't supportive materials could make a
successful surfboard
foam is just a dead piece of material it
doesn't have a spring or a life to it
whereas wood is a you know you bend a
piece of wood it springs right back to
it
surfboards right now are not sustainable
except for wooden surfboards and we need
to move millions and millions of people
towards products like those that are
built to last built from dramatically
sustainable materials materials that
actually sequester carbon you know out
of the air and lock it away in the
surfboard under your feet
just thinking about the materials that
go into the surfboards that we use is
really important because i i don't want
to be surfing a surfboard that
has to be replaced every year
the wood kind of is the starting point
dictates what kind of board we're going
to build
i use a lot of different locally sourced
salvage wood from walnut
to redwood
cypress
all kinds of different wood
the wood that i'm building this board
out of is pretty special wood it's out
of an old victorian from san francisco
so i select the pieces that are going to
be appropriate
bring that into the shop here
and i use the chop saw to cut to length
the panels start out pretty raw the
edges are rough
there's not a true straight edge on
anywhere
and so i used the festool track saw that
goes into the track
and cuts an incredibly accurate straight
line through the panel of wood
[Music]
and then i'm taking those two separate
pieces and gluing them together to
create the panel that will become the
surfboard
once i create the panels i template the
outline of the board into
the top of those panels so you end up
with essentially the outline of the
surfboard in a flat panel of redwood
after that i take that to the bandsaw
and rough cut the outline of the
surfboard
what i'm doing is creating a top panel
a bottom panel that are the shape of the
surfboard
i also rough cut the frame parts that
create the interior and rail parts of
the surfboard
and those are the banana shaped pieces
that you see me cutting out
essentially what they're doing is
creating a hollow cavity inside the
surfboard which removes a ton of weight
but also makes them really strong
so i create those frame parts
and i take them onto the table router
and true them up so that each part is
identical to each other
and then i take it into the shaping room
and use a japanese hand plane
as well as a belt sander
it creates a nice true part that has
nice clean edges on it
and i do that on all the parts because
you want to have clean pieces that you
can accurately cut and assemble
i've made thousands of surfboards so i
can really tr i really feel like i've
developed
a real trust in my eye
it took me many many surfboards to get
to that point where i feel very
confident and comfortable with that
surfboards are essentially a blend of
art and science and you really have to
do the science part the measuring the
math and everything at the beginning and
then when you are really into the curves
and the complex radiuses of the board
you really have to trust the art of it
about 2 000 boards into it
i started feeling like i just know what
this needs to look like
but it took a lot of
measuring and
concentrating to get to that point
so the rocker is super fundamental part
of what makes a surfboard work
it's the bottom curve of the surfboard
if you have a flat surfboard it's just
gonna go really fast but the nose is
gonna poke and you're gonna go over the
front if you have a really rockered
surfboard it's just gonna push water and
bog so you need to have an accurate
curve
so to create that curved frame
i take those two interior frame parts
and i roll glue between them i use this
10 minute cure time really fast poly
expanding polyurethane glue it's really
amazing stuff but it kicks really fast
so when you roll it out all your clamps
are ready your parts are ready you're
ready and you throw it in the mold clamp
it down and just run those clamps around
it really fast
it sits in that mold for two hours under
all that pressure
then you pull all the clamps off and it
holds that curve
a lot of wooden surfboards back in the
day were made from big blocks of wood
and they would carve all that wood out
so there's all this wasted wood in the
nose and tail
whereas with this i'm maximizing the use
of the wood that i'm using and bending
it into the curve which i think creates
a much stronger surfboard the frame
and also just is way more efficient
you're not wasting any of the wood
an all wooden surfboard is going to be a
surfboard that's made from petroleum
materials any day all day it's going to
outlast it it's going to outperform it
so i want to make sure to give danny the
props that he deserves his boards will
be around for hundreds of years because
they are tough because they don't break
and they have great performance people
are going to want to keep them and keep
them around
[Music]
for the next step
i take it into the shaping room the
shaving room was designed with really
specific side lights
i take it in there and strip all the
glue off to just get it all cleaned up
i fine-tune it with my power planer to
clean up all the edges
[Music]
and then i take the power planer and i
put the foil into the frame
the foil is if you think about the way
an airplane wing looks if you look at
the profile of it it's elliptical
surfboards have a foil to them just as
an airplane wing does
so you're putting that foil into the
bottom and the top of that frame
and that gives you a refined internal
panel piece that you take back into the
rocker bed and then take the deck panel
which is a full panel of wood and bend
that back into the rocker bed with glue
and clamp it all up all the way down
each piece is different when you try and
do them all the same time they can crack
and break and they become very
temperamental you're just asking too
much out of the wood when you do it in
steps like that you're able to really
manipulate the wood in in a way that you
wouldn't if you really try to force it
[Music]
at this point i've glued together the
deck the interior frame and the bottom
of the board
and it's essentially looking like a
surfboard it has the rough outline of a
surfboard
and that's when you start laying your
master template on there and that
creates your guide points for really
drawing the curve
every shaper has their master templates
and the templates that they've created
over just many years of evolving their
designs and this one is a template i
call the bella it's named after a
friend's daughter
the marks that i'm marking on the deck
of the surfboard basically dictate the
width that the surfboard needs to be and
then you're marking the nose and tail
dimension those dimensions are all super
important to create a really nice
blending curve
that is pleasing to your eye
at this point i really sharpen my tools
especially on old salvaged redwood you
need to have really tuned sharp tools
and so i'll take out my sharpening
blocks and really put some time into
getting them razor sharp
at that point you have your shape set
you have your length set you have your
width set you have all your other
dimensions set
so from there i take up the power planer
and really start truing up the outline
to the shape that the board is going to
be
and once i true up the outline of the
board
i flip it over and sand out the bottom
with my festool sander
and that really evens the whole bottom
out and blends it all
from there i map out my rail bands on
the bottom which are the
curve of the rail of the surfboard
and i take the power planer again and
just start putting that rail band in so
it's from sharp edge to soft edge to
sharper edge from nose to tail and you
bring that in until you feel the right
curvature
then i take the japanese block plane and
i really tune that rail i remove any
little ridge
and then i lift it up and the underarm
test is the true test of shaper like you
put it under your arm and you feel that
bottom edge and you know when it gets to
the point where it's right
then i take my sanding stick and i just
shape in and blend in all those little
rough edges that are left from the power
tools in the back plane
and then i flip it over onto the deck
and start taking the material out of the
deck
that process is removing a lot of
material and once i get that to the
point that i want it
i take the festool sander and really
blend in all those rough shaving marks
then i'm using the power planter to
blend the top rail into the bottom rail
i'm putting that curve into the board at
that point
and essentially this is the point where
it's gone from becoming a block of wood
to a surfboard
and then i sand it
fine tuning those curves
then the shape of the board is done it's
finished sanded it's ready for fin
markings
this one is specifically is a twin fin
so i take my fin template mark the
outline of the fin
rough cut that out on the bandsaw
and then true that up on the stationary
belt sander and then take that outline
of the fin into my shaping room and
clamp it down on my shaping stand
and take my angle grinder and put in the
foil which is that teardrop shape
and then you have a fin that's ready to
be cut into the bottom of that board
and then i just put my hess stamp on the
tail
write the dimensions which are the
length the width the thickness of the
board
from there i take my silk screen and
stick it onto the deck of the board
silk screen it on there
flip it over do the same on the bottom
and essentially you've got a finished
board that just needs to be sealed
[Music]
i have this specific natural oil called
monocoat that i use to seal the board
and it's a really amazing oil that just
penetrates deep into the redwood and
really creates a shell or skin that
repels water
i oil the fins at that point put my
special glue on the very base of the fin
the bottom and wedge it into the slot
make sure the fins in the exact right
position
and then essentially there you go you
have a finished surfboard
so at this point the board's done and
you just have to be patient wait for the
oil to dry the fins to dry and then i
usually get so excited i just paddle out
whatever ways i can find and just
because i know i want to feel the board
i want to feel it moves to the water and
that's the best part as soon as you kind
of baptize the surfboard
you feel how it pushes under waves
and you know as soon as you paddle for a
wave it engages it catches the wave
smoothly quickly and that first bottom
turn tells you so much in terms of how
that board's going to work because each
board has its own personality
that's such an exciting part because
there's so much anticipation i have this
idea i want to make the surfboard work
this way for this specific wave and then
that moment of truth
yes it works
that's the best feeling
surfboard builders like danny hess are
not just a symbol of sustainability for
our sport they're the absolute pinnacle
right
our hope is that the rest of the
surfboard industry can adopt some of
those same practices that danny and
others have particularly with wooden
surfboards and incorporate them into the
mass producer board so that we're
dramatically lowering the impact that
they're making and hopefully even
leaving a positive legacy in their wake
[Music]
you